cinq cents ans après sa mort léonard de
vinci qui toujours les artistes
le peintre et hommes de science italien
est l'une des inspirations de jocelyne
brise l'est il ya un rembrandt il ya
velasquez
il y à goya beaucoup il ya plusieurs
références sur goya
il y a aussi dans lé content pour un
petit peu plus contemporain j'ai quand
même quelques petites références à
matisse je travaille sur le thème de la
référence
sur la l'histoire de l'art
je prends soin les portraits de peintre
ou soit des extraits de leurs oeuvres et
je les retrouve parfois les retransforme
où je mets une pointe d'humour ou une
note historique contemporaine
l'artiste morte asine créé depuis 25 ans
de la peinture à la gravure c'est le
thème qui conduit la création pour cette
exposition pensé comme une rétrospective
jocelyne brisé a choisi comme fil rouge
la couleur la couleur la chaleur de
cette couleur toutes les nuances qui
peut y avoir
et puis aussi la symbolique de cette
couleur qui peut représenter la violence
le sang la joie aussi que tout de même
enfin mon quelque chose de fort quand
même c'est une couleur forte
une cinquantaine d'oeuvres sont
rassemblés au sein de l'atelier où elles
ont été créées un moyen pour l'artiste
d'initier les curieux à des techniques
parfois oubliés